comment on peut dire des choses qu'on
dont on fait un pas vers les réseaux
sociaux vous animez beaucoup contre
claude excusez-moi contre clubs n'ont
pas de lui j'ai parlé une fois de lui
pendant mon m m'a diffusion sur les
réseaux vous en parlait souvent malades
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous avez parlé de sa vie privée dans le
dernier public de ses parents comme et
comment il le prend sa paris cap a bien
pris mais nous pour nous c'était une
information ça fait vendre idem aux pays
bas là il en a trop de couvin c'était
pas la peine il est très proche de ses
parents donc forcément leur divorce a un
impact aussi peut-être sur ses
performances sportives donc
malheureusement ses côtés là commence sa
carrière c'était monsieur parfait oui
jouer bien il était chanteuse joue pour
bien me donner à des assauts ce il a été
un jour il avait sais pas s'ils toussent
et d'allumer un peu et quand tout d'un
coup effectivement venant public sur un
énorme bateau à mykonos avec 15 filles
magnifiques dessus bien sûr mais c'est
vrai qu'on a besoin de mecs un tout
petit peu vrillé quoi jouons avec des
bâtiments caixinha moi je les ai suivis
et un moment des faits sont punis c'est
drôle je sais pas dit ce n'était pas le
meilleur mais mathieu franchement c
franchement dire qu'il est égoïste qui
l'appelle
c'est là une toute petite facette demba
p voyez plutôt l'homme généraux mais
générosité ou bien ces symboles
tâche il disait notre foot c'est un foot
de jean mesquin et jaloux ouais en fait
je trouve que tu es jaloux
notion d c'est vraiment un événement
trouve tout l'événement du jour vraiment
je te lis premier plus grands gagnants
de jeu télé en france 92 coup de maître
9 étoiles mystérieux dans la légende que
des bases bon ça veut dire qu'il a gagné
plein de trucs 252 participation ta
première participation c'est le vosges
bas-rhin janvier 2021 c'est vrai presque
neuf mois de présence à l'antenne on
peut être ya justement les gens se
posent une question c'est que heu toi tu
avais tu avais un travail ou pas
absolument mais que j'ai perdus en cours
d'émission c'est ça pourquoi parce que
t'es trop dans l'émission non il y avait
un plan dans le
monde si je compte faire un plan
je suis donc je pensais que j'avais à
peu près un niveau acceptable pour faire
un jeu télé donc j'espérais quand même
en gagner deux ou trois alors mais c'est
vrai que évidemment on se projette pas
du tout en se disant je vais tenir neuf
mois et battre tous les records en vain
on a plein de questions à se poser sur
que les téléspectateurs aussi illuminé
aujourd'hui ouais mais l'émission est
enregistrée et ça fait même très un sens
puisque c'est le cri pour perdu le 16
juillet 7 juillet enregistre et le 16
juillet et ma défaveur aujourd'hui donc
si je comprends bien bruno donc le 16
juillet tu es éliminé exactement à rien
2 on n'a rien ni en argent ni en cas ici
puisque là mon parcours était tellement
long as well fatigue paye trois mois
après ce que j'ai touché donc c'est à
dire que ce que j'ai gagné dans les
émissions diffusées en janvier j'étais
l'un cheikh en avril mais j'ai adoré
avril tous les mois je reçois un chèque
est pour moi démission les belles
histoires
sur les cent mille
cutro descente une petite d un petit peu
de dépression c'est vrai qu'en plus
comme j'ai pas de travail j'ai pas de
mec j'avais tout seul du coup le
lendemain c'est refaire les autres
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
comme jeudi champion des jeux télé c'est
pas un métier donc retrouver ma vie ma
famille mes amis du repos placer
l'argent voilà comme disait acheter des
biens et puis après on verra vallejo
travaillé comme dit oui toi songez que
trente ans donc un effet pas passé 50
ans à nous faire faire
bernard bouttier
[Applaudissements]
mercier ami ami brian trop de physique
chimie merci d'être là aussi parce que
c'est pourquoi je dois devenir ce soir
défendre le cas de ryan qui a été
vraiment au centre de toutes les
polémiques sur les réseaux sociaux dans
une succession de stories sur les
réseaux sociaux jeune homme qui se fait
appeler ryan n'a pas hésité à insulter
les sapeurs alors qu'ils étaient en
train de travailler qui rend encore
pendant qu'ils étaient à l'intérieur de
l'école le jeune homme s'est précipité
dans leur camion pour prendre des photos
mais aussi pour leur voler du matériel
hi arena pétain alors intrusion dans un
camion de pompier menace l'auteur des
faits a lâché est ce un scandale sachez
donc que c'est moi qui ai appelé les
pompiers pour venir à l'école je
travaille dans cette école moi j'appelle
les pompiers et que j'ai une j'ai une
enfant qui est qui est en train de
perdre contre connaissance à ce moment
là les confirmés d écouter il faut
absolument que vous la mc2 mon enseigne
éveillé ok la personne qui m'a aidé à la
maintenir à billère bien le clown en
faisant ses blagues habituelles c'était
qui s'était ryan ryan ils étaient là
avec moi il l'a maintenu éveillé jusqu'à
que les pompiers viennent quand les
pompiers sont venus ok les pompiers ont
été aucunement dérangé pendant leur
travail de nos vidéos énormément parler
j'y viens j'ai levé la vidéo sur les
policiers
pas bien avec ta bouche natiembé ryan il
est mauvais on lui a pas appris qu'on
montait dans un camion de pompier pour
faire des doigts d'honneur sauter laisse
moi faire mieux c'est l'essai par
l'étrier mal élevés on vole pas les
outils il a volé des outils les jetons
ryan qui est mal mais quand on a rien à
[ __ ] des institutions qui dit
c'est qu'ils donnent il dit des termes
il dit allahou akbar il parle de mieux
sur ces très foot ou les
essais chez lui là tout musulman dans la
vie des gens qui sont musulmans quand
rien demandé qui font rien sur il se
lève le matin qu'ils aillent bosser me
grâce à leurs réseaux sociaux pour ce
mec là c'est un petit con mal élevés je
le dis et j'assume p
[Applaudissements]
comprenez vous les critiques contre
claude de koh lanta ça a été en top twin
toute la journée on va montrer les
interventions thonière soit d'avoir
cette grande travers donc tu vas attaché
à la taille des conneries
moi je peux pas ne vous laisse faire
charlotte toi tu étais dans l'aventuré
avec lui est ce que tu es d'accord avec
ce qui s'est dit qu'aucun aient été
jugés arrogants et manipulateur ou pas
du tout déjà là on voit à claude enfin
quand on parle de claude puel au début
de l'émission là en l'occurrence et sur
les épreuves et il est très fort et
c'est alors oui ça on peut pas lui
enlever un à côté de ça il ya l'humain
il ya la personne qu'il est et ouest est
un manipulateur c'est en fin stratège
en effet c'est c'est quelqu'un qui peut
être arrogant film arabe et c'est déjà
en tant que femme ça soit physiquement
sur mon corps à me dire mais n'était pas
sportif toi mais je comprends pas mais
attends mais là c'est tout mais non mais
il ya des blagues et iard abc la femme
en tant que tel devant tout le monde et
rigoler et même lorsque j'étais plus
dans le jeu ça rigolait encore sur sur
sa sur le corps son machin je vous dise
en tout cas parce qu'elle n'aime pas du
tout claude on est que et que charlotte
et que charlotte et elle n'est même pas
que j'aime hollis démolissent sur les
réseaux sociaux en interne avec d'autres
candidats claude en permanence donc je
pense que le témoignage de charlotte je
vous respecte infiniment est très
orientée et que vous êtes manipulés
madame je comprends pas comment on peut
dire des choses qu'on en fait un pas que
c'était les réseaux sociaux vous animez
beaucoup contre claude excusez-moi entre
globalement pas de lui j'ai parlé une
fois de lui pendant
ma diffusion sur les raisons vous en
parlait souvent malade mais cette fois
ci pas qu'alors qu'elle est orientée
dire ça ressort témoins qu'à une chose
où je parle de de claude aujourd'hui
animations et demi que j'ai pas dis
quelque chose sur chloé beaucoup de
témoignages d'anciens candidats on parle
aussi il ya une rumeur qu'il ans si je
le dis d'impact à quatre bogueys chacun
25 euros qu'est ce que c'est que cette
histoire dans koh lanta c'est beaucoup
cessionnaire c'est quoi cette histoire
de nous ça existait un témoin on y voit
cinq ans l'a fait on dit quoi si en
argonne stockage mois ouais en 2005 on
l'a fait clémence on l'a fait avec
combat avec ses rives a fait nous on l'a
fait on savait que quand on savait qu'on
allait arriver à plusieurs en finale
elle voulait pas qu'un indien qui
prennent le gain du coup on l'a partagée
à cinq éléments j'ai entendu ça par
rapport à toute cette année là enfin
cette année c'est à dire qu'il aurait
fait un pacte aussi avec chine avec
laurent et avec une autre une autre
aventure hier moi je suis assez étonné
parce que la production vient nous voir
le producteur vient nous voir en nous
menaçant si vous faites ça vous verrez
plus jamais vous ferez koh lanta nom de
l'agent la formation en interne certains
cas aujourd'hui clément cela fait douze
saisons je comprends pas
cette histoire je veux la vie d'une
seule et unique personne de qui il est
en colère et çà et là ce soir qui rogers
texan
[Applaudissements]
oui c'est
ça peut commencer bien sûr lui qui me
déçoit le plus c'est moi pas les
attaquer un pays il est d'origine
d'alsace hockey y est ils l'invitent de
fines à manger chaque fois tac des
pièces ms
n'aurait-on métier
[Applaudissements]
je suis désolé c'était mon frère une
entente très bien à chaque fois oui mais
oui je suis et j'ai de place dans la
voiture
et puis l'histoire d'un laponie quand
même alors à saint germain benjamin
franchement m'a déçu quand je suis
arrivé ici à trois ans avec delphine
c'est la première personne connue avec
qui j'ai fait un selphy une photo à la
une célébrité et là il les envoie il
envoie des messages tout ça aulas j'ai
dit à delphine delphine tu peux pas
avoir un truc avec ce mec on a ces
dettes c'est bon
[Rires]
à
ma fille m'a dit
[Applaudissements]
merci
et voilà
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]